dr fellow scanners this is when mister
pepper sweet caruso knife share this
project is a collaboration between in
lea and facebook a year research and is
about process team is angry as
team agree we sign input photo or
in the cooler kees video  of people and
the output should be a description of
their posters
this is kind of like motion
capture movie en computer game
animations boss what time the studio and the
markers this workflows ivens further and
tries to offer for free the
reconstruction of the geometry of  the
buddies and it is and often doing re more
than that enzyme ace in him and the agency
networks and usually great app die tests
provided we have large number of
training offer to train then so the first
up is gathering large amount of notk
this means a  input photographer of
someone who share day good correct
description of there past er this is what
we call my training offer
this new propose did set contains
15.000 of thi  s training samples and
using that we can proceed to step number
to group training the neural network the
perform wrist estimation benefit this more
to this particular work normally
disposed emission takes place for the to
the skeleton must lubricate city had acne
is output the stick video with  not in this
case week if the details can be a
segmentation and des correspondances
between two the images and 3d models
therefore de network is oro label de
output fully family marvel's there
plenty of interesting that phone in the
paper for instance since that one type
grande rue  foods in the training set is
created by humans with plenty of missing
dhr is fiat in by using
seperate nu al network de the specialized
for this task make sure to have look at
the paper for more cool details like
this this assange bed in series with the
practical  application has to be a robust
gaston cushions and dropping changes in
posture and the good thing is dat die
offers habilis plenty of ik sample  es we
die is that your cashier absolutely has to be
able to deal with smaller en bidder
ski jacket with bi-polar closer
or further away from the camera this is
absolutely challenge the ugly john darley
de job at snv member no markers for
studio setup  is required and en
direction you are distorted
interactively
the details edwina pierson end it will be
possible to use it for future research
words suspect
plenty of molecule operation and
follow-up words for this problem while
leaving and sing along
searching for  your generous support na
see you next time
[Music]